gelähmte sollen wieder gehen Blinde
wieder sehen können und alle
neurologischen Probleme sollen gelöst
werden nicht weniger als das verspricht
Elon Musk erreichen will er das mit dem
brain machine Interface seiner Firma
nura Link und das hirnimplantat könnte
schon dieses Jahr an Menschen getestet
werden aber welche technischen Hürden
müssen dafür noch überwunden werden wer
hat überhaupt Interesse an so einem
Gerät in seinem Kopf und sind seine
Versprechen wirklich glaubwürdig wir
haben eine Neurowissenschaftler mit über
10 Jahren Erfahrung gefragt dieses Video
hier für uns zu recherchieren und was er
dabei gefunden hat Recht von potentiell
bahnbrechenden Innovationen über
moralisch fragwürdige versprechen bis
hin zu kompletten Wahnsinn wieso nur
links die Medizin nicht revolutionieren
wird darum geht es heute
[Musik]
vor ein paar Wochen haben wir ein ganzes
Video zum Thema Artensterben gemacht
wenn euch unser Planet auch so im Herzen
liegt wie uns und ihr die beeindruckende
Arbeit von artenschützern sehen wollt
die gerade Europas größte Säugetier vom
Aussterben zurückbringen dann bleibt
unbedingt bis zum Ende dieses Videos
hier dran dann empfehle ich euch nämlich
ein ganz besonderes Video das mich total
umgehauen hat
nur links soll ein generelles full Rain
machine Interface bauen ein Gerät das
man in den Schädel einsetzt und das über
viele tausend Elektroden mit Neuronen im
gesamten Gehirn kommuniziert eine
künstliche Intelligenz soll noch im
implantierten Gerät die Signale
verarbeiten und komprimiert über eine
kabellose Verbindung an dein Smartphone
weitergeben Apps auf dem Handy wiederum
können das Interface anweisen bestimmte
Neuronen anzuregen oder zu hemmen der
Mensch soll so Gedanken schnell mit
Maschinen kommunizieren können und die
Maschine soll die Menschen bei seinem
Gehirnfunktionen
helfen was auch immer das bedeutet das
Prinzip ist nicht grundsätzlich neu
Schnittstellen zwischen Gehirn und
Computer werden seit dem 1990er Jahren
für Forschungszwecke entwickelt wegen
der ethischen Bedenken kommen für solche
Experimente aber nur wenige ausgewählte
Patienten oder Patientinnen in Frage
noch weniger Stimmen zu denn der
Eingriff ist gesundheitlich sehr riskant
weltweit wurden bisher weniger als 40
Menschen BMI ist eingepflanzt
das will nur Link ändern Ihr System soll
so zuverlässig und sicher werden dass
Menschen es sich sogar als Lifestyle
Gerät einpflanzen würden und es soll
viel leistungsfähiger sein als die
aktuelle Technologie und direkt mal
vorweg die Neurowissenschaft beobachtet
das Unternehmen mit gemischten Gefühlen
auf der einen Seite sind die technischen
Innovationen natürlich hilfreich um die
Forschungsarbeit zu erleichtern zu den
medizinischen Hals versprechen Lähmung
Alzheimer Depressionen sind die
Expertenmeinungen allerdings
differenzierter aber kommen wir erstmal
zum technischen Teil
die erste Zielmarke ist das System
abzulösen dass im Moment für die
Forschung benutzt wird das
Utah Array mit dem europort von
Blackrock nur Tech das ist gar nicht so
schwierig denn die Nachfrage nach BMI
ist wie gesagt extrem gering und die für
eine Zulassung notwendigen
Sicherheitsnachweise sind teuer dem Utah
Array Konkurrenz zu machen ist also
nicht wirtschaftlich und deswegen macht
es auch keiner entsprechend hat das
Jutta Array auch noch den Charme der
Jahrtausendwende ein sperriger Adapter
der nur robot ist am Schädel befestigt
und ein dickes Kabel verbindet das
Interface mit dem Computer der Port wird
dabei auch durch eine offene Wunde am
Kopf das bedeutet ein ständiges Risiko
für lebensgefährliche Entzündungen im
Gehirn
nur links N1 Prototyp ist da ein großer
Schritt vorwärts das kleine runde Gerät
wird in den Schädel integriert und
kommuniziert per Bluetooth keine Kabel
keine offenen Wunden das macht das Leben
für die Versuchspersonen natürlich viel
einfacher und sicherer das neue Design
hat aber auch seine eigenen technischen
Schwierigkeiten Bluetooth hat zu wenig
Bandbreite um das rohsignal zu
übertragen deshalb muss ein großer Teil
der Signalverarbeitung auf dem Implantat
selber stattfinden dadurch wird das
Gerät aber heißt was für das Gehirn
gefährlich werden kann in eins hat
aktuell 1024 aufnahmekanäle für einzelne
Elektroden damit ziehen sie mit dem Utah
Array gleich und sie haben angekündigt
bald über 16.000 Kanäle in das Implantat
zu integrieren ohne es zu vergrößern für
die Hirnforschung ist das ein feuchter
Traum denn bisher bleiben bmi's meist
unter 1024 Kanälen aber bevor wir uns zu
sehr freuen verarbeiten kann das in eins
davon erst 64 Kanäle gleichzeitig
ganz besonders innovativ sind nur links
Elektroden das uter Array hat starre
Elektroden die aus einer Platine
hervorstehen sieht so ein bisschen aus
wie ein sehr kleines Nagelbrett bei
jeder Bewegung können Platine und
Elektroden Mikroverletzungen verursachen
die vernarben das Narbengewebe isoliert
dann die Elektroden und macht sie
nutzlosing verwendet deshalb Elektrode
also farbenförmige Elektroden die sind
so dünn und flexibel dass sie sich mit
dem Gehirn bewegen das soll schonender
sein und die Lebensdauer des Geräts
verlängern aber das ist noch nicht alles
auch die Implantation ist revolutionär
für das Jutta Array muss ein Chirurg ein
Loch in den Schädel und die
mehrschichtige Schutzhaut des Gehirns
schneiden die Elektroden werden dann mit
Druckluft ins Gehirn gestempelt quasi
nur Link entwickelt stattdessen einen
Roboter der viel präziser schonender und
schneller arbeiten kann jede Elektrode
wird einzeln eingepflanzt ohne
Blutgefäße zu verletzen die Schädel OP
ist noch in der Entwicklung aber für das
einsetzen Elektroden wird der Roboter
jetzt schon genutzt
neben der Vernarbung ist auch das stark
korrodierende feucht salzige Milieu im
Körper ein Problem ein Implantat das
jahrzehntelang funktionsfähig bleiben
soll darf sich ja nicht mit der Zeit
auflösen das Utah Array ist bisher
maximal neun Jahre in Benutzung so lange
gibt es nur links noch gar nicht
immerhin soll das N1 mehr als anderthalb
Jahre lang in einem Versuchstier
funktioniert haben andere Tiere tragen
das Implantat laut eigenen Angaben seit
fast einem Jahr ohne
Funktionseinschränkungen wie häufig ein
implantiertes N1 aber versagt hat das
sagt uns nur Links nicht das Thema
Tierversuche ist für Norwegen auch
ziemlich heikel Mitarbeiter haben
schwere Vorwürfe gegen die Firma erhoben
dass das Tierwohl vernachlässigt worden
sein soll unter anderem der
Leistungsdruck durch Elon Musk soll dazu
führen dass viele Tiere unnötigerweise
leiden und sterben wie immer findet ihr
alle Quellen von uns unten in der
Videobeschreibung solange das Verfahren
noch andauert möchten wir das nicht
weiter kommentieren solche Vorwürfe
werden oft erhoben manchmal zu Unrecht
und manchmal zurecht nur Link ist
jedenfalls darauf bedacht zu erklären
wie sie Tierversuche vermeiden zum
Beispiel testen Sie die Langlebigkeit
des Implantats nicht in Tieren sondern
in speziellen testbehältern dort läuft
die Korrosion viermal so schnell wie im
Körper basierend auf diesen Tests könnte
ein neuer Link Implantat 8 Jahre
funktionsfähig bleiben nur Link hat
bereits 2020 demonstriert dass der
Grundstein für ein modernes und
leistungsstarkes BMI gelegt ist und
technologisch ist nur links Interface
auf dem Weg neue Standards zu setzen für
die neurowissenschaftliche
Grundlagenforschung ist es je nach
Forschungsfrage etwas unpraktisch dass
man keinen Zugriff auf die Rohdaten hat
aber für die Entwicklung medizinische
Anwendungen muss das kein Hindernis sein
als forschungsgerät könnte nur links
Interface das Utah Ray vielleicht bald
ablösen okay die Hardware ist also
ziemlich cool und beeindruckend aber wie
sieht es mit der medizinischen Anwendung
aus wird nur allerdings Interface
Menschen mit neurologischen und
psychiatischen Problemen helfen können
[Musik]
der mind-pong Spielende rhesusaffe hat
nicht nur gezeigt dass nur links
Interface funktioniert er demonstriert
auch die mögliche Anwendung als Ersatz
für Maus und Tastatur für gelähmte
Menschen nur allerdings Konkurrenz
synchron entwickelt schon ein BMI
speziell dafür seit 2021 testen Sie Ihr
Gerät erfolgreich in Menschen allerdings
ist die telepathische Steuerung bei
beiden Systemen viel langsamer und
schwieriger als die Bedienung mit der
Hand also nichts für Performance
bewusste Gamer wie mich z.B nur links
Entwickler reden auch gern von Plug and
Play aber so einfach wie das klingt wird
es wohl nie werden das derzeitige System
bei nura Link hat eine KI die lernen
muss die Aktivitätsmuster im Gehirn den
Handbewegungen zuzuweisen für jeden
Menschen muss das neue trainiert werden
gelähmt die Menschen können die
Handbewegungen aber nicht machen was das
Training schwieriger und langwieriger
macht auch der Mensch muss dann den
Umgang mit einem BMI erstmal lernen
außerdem gibt es sichere und
preisgünstigere Alternativen man kann
zum Beispiel flache Elektroden auf die
Hirnhaut legen oder man bringt
Elektroden auf der Kopf an ganz ohne
Operation das habe ich zum Beispiel
schon mal gemacht man kann auch
elektrische Signale von
Muskelkontraktionen benutzen anstatt
Nervenimpulsen das Gehirn bleibt dabei
dann ganz unangetastet
eine ähnliche Anwendung die nur Link
verfolgt ist die Überbrückung von
Rückenmarksverletzungen dabei steuert
man keine Prothese oder Computer sondern
ein zweites Implantat im Rückenmark
unterhalb der Verletzung an wenn das
zweite Implantat die richtigen Neuronen
in der richtigen Reihenfolge stimuliert
ruft das Bewegungen von Armen und Beinen
hervor mit so einem System könnten
gelähmte also vielleicht ihre
Beweglichkeit zurück erlangen nur links
Interface könnte auch sehen oder
Hörgeschädigten helfen hierbei werden
Signale aus einer Kamera oder eine
Mikrofon erst übersetzt und dann in den
entsprechenden Teil des Gehirns
übertragen für Hörbehinderte gibt es das
schon nur Link und einige ihrer
Konkurrenten arbeiten derzeit an einem
System für Sehbehinderte ein anderer
Ansatz wäre die Netzhaut mit einem Chip
zu ersetzen was besser ist kommt darauf
an ob das Problem im Auge oder im Sinne
fliegt für die Anwendung im Cortex ist
die zielgenaue Stimulation durch die
Elektroden extrem wichtig das Problem
die elektrischen Signale breiten sich im
Gehirn aus ile Mast räumt selbst dass
jede Stimulation hunderte bis tausende
Neuronen gleichzeitig erwischt in der
Forschung wird das Problem gelöst indem
man Elektroden mit einem großen
elektrischen Widerstand in direkten
Kontakt mit einem Neuron bringt und dann
vorsichtig festsaugt die kleinste
Erschütterung kann diesen Kontakt aber
wieder lösen für ein BMI ist das keine
brauchbare Methode und die Elektro
Threads haben laut nur Link auch eher
einen kleinen Widerstand okay also
diesen Teil über Neuroprothesen mal
zusammengefasst nur Link wird vermutlich
mit bereits existierenden Lösungen
gleich ziehen weil es aber vor einige
Anwendungen preisgünstigere und
sicherere Konkurrenz gibt wird die
Nachfrage wahrscheinlich sehr gering
ausfallen nur bei schweren Behinderungen
die andere technische Lösungen
ausschließen würden sich Betroffene ein
Loch in den Kopf fräsen lassen
vorausgesetzt jemand bezahlt das dann
auch
es gibt aber auch Anwendungen da kommt
man um gehirn-ops einfach nicht herum
die Tiefe Hirnstimulation
sehr schwere Fälle von Epilepsie
bestimmten Bewegungsstörungen Parkinson
und sogar Zwangsstörungen werden
manchmal mit hirnschrittmachern
behandelt dafür werden recht große
Elektroden eingesetzt die dann
durchgehen mit einer hohen Frequenz eine
bestimmte Hirnregion stimulieren das
lindert die Symptome warum weiß man noch
gar nicht und schaltet man das Gerät ab
kehren die Symptome sofort zurück auch
für eine Reihe weiterer Krankheiten
forscht man an der Wirksamkeit von DBS
die brainstimulation zum Beispiel soll
es in manchen Fällen das Gedächtnis von
Alzheimer Patienten verbessert haben
aber überprüft und abgesichert sind
diese Ergebnisse noch nicht eine
ernstzunehmende Therapiemethode ist noch
gar nicht in Sicht
eignet sich nur links Interface
überhaupt als dbs-gerät auf der einen
Seite sind die elektronenfäden viel
dünner als die üblichen DBS Elektroden
es könnten also mehr Elektroden in das
betroffene Hirngebiet implantiert werden
ohne die Gesundheitsrisiken zu erhöhen
für die Forschung sicherlich praktisch
auf der anderen Seite braucht es kein
aufwendiges brain machine Interface für
so eine dauerstimulierung die
verhältnismäßig einfachen und robusten
Hirnschrittmacher halten
durchschnittlich 15 Jahre also viel
länger als jedes BMI bisher nur
allerdings Interface ist für die Tiefe
Hirnstimulation und die Prothesen nicht
grundsätzlich ungeeignet andere
Technologien sind zwar auch nicht
perfekt aber bisher zumindest noch
sicherer zuverlässiger und
preisgünstiger ob so ein generelles
brain machine Interface also eine echte
Konkurrenz für spezialisierte
Technologien werden kann
[Musik]
bisher ist nur links Ansatz ganz
spannend nicht wirklich bahnbrechend
aber ein evolutionärer Schritt nach
vorne für die Hirnforschung
unseriös sind aber Elon Musk Versprechen
auch jedes andere Problem im
Nervensystem mit dem BMI zu lösen
skeptisch sollte man schon deshalb sein
weil wir bei den meisten Erkrankungen
und Störungen des Nervensystems noch gar
nicht wissen was da passiert Elon Musk
möchte auch das Gedächtnis in die Cloud
auslagern sicherlich wird nur links
Interface Aktivitätsmuster speichern und
wieder abspielen können Stimulationen an
der richtigen Stelle können auch eine
Erinnerung wieder hervorbringen aber
dass ich Gehirn und Gedächtnis laufen
verändern wird das kaum so einfach und
zuverlässig funktionieren wie sich
Science-Fiction Fans das so vorstellen
auch die Idee dass das Interface
irgendwann gemütserkrankungen und
genetische Störungen wie Autismus
reparieren soll finden wir bedenklich
denn das würde bedeuten dass man über
ein Handy Gefühle und Denkweisen eines
Menschen beeinflussen kann und der
Gedanke ist ziemlich scary
[Musik]
nur links Interface könnte in der
Hirnforschung zu einem wichtigen
Werkzeug werden super spannend sind auch
die Ansätze behinderten Menschen zu
helfen Computer und Prothesen zu steuern
oder Rückenmarksverletzungen zu
überbrücken auch wenn man befürchten
muss dass die Nachfrage dafür gering
bleibt einfach weil es da schon
zuverlässige sichere und preiswerte
Alternativen gibt Elon Musk Versprechen
sind also teils realistisch teils bauen
sie aber auch auf Ideen in der
medizinischen Forschung die noch gar
nicht hinreichend geprüft worden sind
und solange das nicht klar ist sind die
Versprechen in dieser Hinsicht leider
Bullshit da wo die versprechen zumindest
nicht komplett unseriös sind erscheint
uns das N1 also der Prototyp nicht die
optimale Lösung zu sein aus Sicht der
betroffenen Menschen und ich glaube das
liegt daran dass es für einen ganz
anderen Zweck erdacht worden ist nämlich
für must-idee Mensch und künstliche
Intelligenz zu verschmelzen davon redet
er nämlich bei jedem Update und jedem
Interview zu dem Thema
die medizinischen Anwendungen sind da
eher eine nachträgliche Idee schließlich
muss man die Entwicklung ja auch
irgendwie rechtfertigen vor
Ethikkommissionen vor Investoren und vor
potenziellen Mitarbeitern und
Projektpartnern insgesamt halten wir vor
allem die Langzeitpläne für ein
fullbrain Maschinen Interface dass man
mit dem Telefon kontrollieren kann für
gefährlich jetzt gerade wird bei der
amerikanischen Gesundheitsbehörde
geprüft ob nur links dann Implantat an
Menschen testen darf die Entscheidung
wird in den nächsten Monaten erwartet
und wir halten euch natürlich hier auf
dem Kanal auf dem Laufenden und jetzt
noch eine ganz persönliche
videoempfehlung von mir ihr wisst dass
mir Artenschutz am Herzen liegt wenn ihr
ein sehr spannendes und informatives
Video über die wichtige Pionierarbeit
von atemschützern sehen wollt dann
schaut euch dieses Video hier von
unseren Freunden bei Planet wild an sie
haben sich auf die Suche nach Europas
größtem Landsäugetier gemacht um es zu
schützen das europäische Bison galt
bereits als ausgestorben und erlebt nun
ein überraschendes kam weg und es spielt
eine deutlich größere Rolle für unsere
Ökosysteme als ich mir jemals
vorgestellt hätte Planet wild ist eine
neue Initiative bei der ich selbst auch
involviert bin und der jeder beitreten
kann der selbst etwas für den Schutz des
Planeten tun möchte die Community
finanziert weltweite Pionierarbeit zur
Rettung bedrohter Tierarten dem Erhalt
von Urwäldern und dem Schutz der Ozeane
das Planet wild Team setzt dann jeden
Monat im Namen der Community diese
Missionen um und berichtet darin in
Videos wie halt diesem hier falls Ihr
schon immer der Natur etwas zurückgeben
wollte aber vielleicht bisher noch nicht
wusste wie dann solltet ihr euch auf
jeden Fall jetzt Planet wild anschauen
ab 5 € im Monat könnt ihr selbst Teil
der Community werden und dann jeden
Monat sehen was wir gemeinsam bewegen
können das ganze gibt's dann in
unterhaltsamen transparenten und Fakten
reichen YouTube-Videos schaut euch an
und wie immer vielen Dank fürs zuschauen
und bleibt neugierig euer Patrick